act as arkansas senator tom cotton i see
uh a senator you've got the memo about
the color to wear so we're nicely
matched we're twins tonight uh this is
as we're watching this it seems uh it is
like theater but it seems literally
unbelievable
what is your take on uh certainly miss
rollins but in general the crime that is
spiking all across the country
well tammy it's tragic that a crime wave
is crashing all across the country in
places like los angeles and boston i
can't believe the cavalier attitude of
george s gunn to argue incorrectly that
crime is down except for murder so
unless you've been heinously murdered in
los angeles everything is just fine that
clip you showed from rachel rollins
shows why she doesn't have the
temperament to be a u.s attorney let
alone her terrible record as the d.a in
boston as you said she's ruled entire
categories of crimes off-limits from
breaking and entering and destruction of
property and drug possession with intent
to distribute and resisting arrest these
two are part of a broad and disturbing
trend of what's called soros prosecutors
around the country prosecutors who have
been backed by george soros and other
liberal billionaires who have an
ideological belief that our criminal
justice system is racist and needs to be
dismantled what happened this week in
the u.s senate is the first time in 42
years
that there was a recorded vote on a u.s
attorney typically we grant a lot of
deference to the president and the
senators and the two senators from the
state but i put my foot down and said i
wasn't going to allow that to happen on
this one every democratic senator needed
to go on the record that includes maggie
hassan from new hampshire a state that
is dealing with a terrible opioid
problem 80 percent of the drugs in new
hampshire come from massachusetts she
just voted to make rachel rollins the
chief law enforcement officer
of the federal government in
massachusetts maggie hassan is going to
answer that to the voters of the granite
state next fall excellent because this
is going to be a disaster and you know
there's so much talent in the country
to deliberately choose someone who is so
unsuited for such an important position
is remarkable and there is this
commitment you know all it does uh with
the soros approach the far left and
wanting chaos it seems to me that they
have believed they felt that this would
aid them in either growing government or
getting elected
you think that's possible that this is
actually because everything they do
seems to be attached to to the politics
of it that this is now backfiring are
they seeing that well there's no doubt
that these soros prosecutors in the far
left puts ideology up before people and
what happens you get a wake of
destruction and death look in san
francisco we have one of the most most
notorious source prosecutors chez boudin
the city is virtually unlivable the
looting is now so well organized that
the gangs are breaking into the home
depot first to steal all the hammers and
the crowbars and then they go to the
jewelry store in the electronics store
to break in using the hammers and the
crowbars and he dismisses it he
dismisses it as low-level theft and
shoplifting that's why even in liberal
san francisco nancy pelosi's hometown
chase boudin is going to face a recall
election next year and i bet he gets
recalled by people who are fed up with
the assault on crime approach gas going
in los angeles is facing that as well
it's imperative that people in these
communities at least take action to try
to take this back and to make you people
make mistakes people get lied to by
politicians but no one wants this there
is no community you can be a totally
deep blue democrat you don't want people
in la now they're doing the follow home
robberies where they watch you shop and
then they follow you home and then that
you go in there and in one case uh very
prominent a philanthropist a well-known
loved woman was murdered an elderly
woman murdered in her home
by these follow-home robbers murder and
robbery and rape and theft they don't
have a partisan affiliation they affect
everyone equal so in all these cities if
they have recall opportunities they need
to recall their prosecutors if any of
them are elevated to the federal
government i can assure you that it will
pull out all the stops to stop their
nominations from going forward excellent
well thank you sir and thank you for
your all your work and merry christmas